un mar negro en paz y la integridad
territorial en ucrania es lo que quiere
el presidente turco recep tayyip erdogán
según dijo durante una rueda de prensa
con su homólogo ucraniano volodymyr
telesquí surgió nuestro principal
objetivo es asegurarnos de que el mar
negro pueda seguir siendo un mar de paz
y cooperación el nombre de turquía hemos
defendido claramente la integridad
territorial y la soberanía de ucrania la
reunión se produjo luego de las
recientes tensiones en el este de
ucrania en la frontera con rusia el
viernes el presidente del esquí estuvo
en el frente militar de una de las zonas
más peligrosas del donbass y fueron 26
los militares muertos los militares
hacen todo lo posible para defender
nuestro país y mantener el alto al fuego
pero cuando se ataca a nuestros soldados
y hay víctimas está claro que el
ejército responde
[Música]
al respecto rusia dijo que bajo ciertas
circunstancias respondería de vuelta y
con fuerza
[Música]
el inicio de la acción militar sería el
principio del fin para ucrania
ambas partes se culpan entre ellas por
la intensificación de los combates que
han empeorado durante las últimas
semanas dejando escenas como esta las
tropas rusas se acumulan a lo largo de
la frontera como respuesta a la presión
internacional que pide su retirada el
presidente putin dijo que sus soldados
están allí para desescalar las tensiones
provocadas por los combates en el
donbass comenzaron en 2014 cuando rusia
se anexionó la península de crimea un
año después se acordó un alto al fuego
fruto de los acuerdos de mills mediados
por francia y alemania- pero los
bombardeos y los enfrentamientos
ocasionales en la región del donbass
nunca han cesado